[Music]
[Applause]
over the course of 35 years and 20 plus
games we've seen a wide array of
recurring groups and characters zora
gorons rito koroks and more have all
been brought back at least once to play
a part in link's adventure once again
and yet at the same time there are also
those who've only been featured in one
game and are never seen again after that
say for some small references and
nothing more which brings us to the
minish also known as the picori to the
hylians though fun fact this is actually
unique to the english version of minish
cap alone yes for the other language
versions including japanese this
distinction doesn't exist and both
hylians and minish use the same name i
have no idea why they decided to change
this for the english version but let's
just say it wouldn't be the first time
that nintendo of america altered emitted
or inserted their own ideas into a zelda
game diminish are one of my personal
favorite creatures in the entire series
tiny thumb-sized beings who resemble
anthropomorphic mice and made their
debut in 2004's the legend of zelda
minish cap they remind me a lot of the
borrowers from arietti which as of right
now is in my top 5 miyazaki films
however unlike the borrowers the minish
are completely invisible to most people
in that regard they have a lot more in
common with the koroks who are also said
to be invisible except to those who are
pure of heart particularly children but
a big difference between the koroks and
the minish is that their origin is not
found inside the kingdom of hyrule but
rather a mysterious dimension called the
minish realm they even have their own
highly complex language
funnily enough they are perhaps most
famous for being the ones responsible as
to why link keeps finding rupees and
other trinkets hidden inside grass and
empty jars as it's said to be their way
of offering gifts and good fortune to
the hylians something that before this
game was just a funny unexplained staple
of the zelda series but their influence
on hyrule cannot be underestimated and
goes far beyond just leaving behind
small collectibles despite their size
they've had a huge impact on the outcome
of events in the battle between good and
evil mostly for the better but in one
particular case for the worst being one
of my favorite zelda creatures i had
honestly given up all hope that we would
ever see them again nintendo has had
plenty of opportunities to bring them
back as there are no less than 7 games
which were released after diminished cap
you can also imagine my disappointment
when i found out that nintendo did
actually have plans to include a race of
tiny beings in the latest zelda epic
breath of the wild but was ultimately
scrapped to meet the deadline link would
have had the ability to shrink down to
their size and interact with them
similar to the 2004 game boy advance
title something which probably required
too much additional programming to get
it done in time remember breath of the
wild was already delayed like four times
now it only exists as yet another idea
of what could have been hidden away in
developer notes and a single screenshot
but then something happened which at the
time wasn't something most people were
expecting a direct sequel to breath of
the wild was announced one of only a few
direct sequels in the zelda timeline not
only that but it stars the same main
characters and takes place in the same
world no less which is actually a first
for the series so knowing what we know
now are there any hints or at least
possible story implications that would
warrant the return of hyrule's tiniest
heroes well yes and surprisingly more
than you would think the first and most
obvious one of course being the fact
that as stated before there were
minish-like beings conceptualized for
breath of the wild and nintendo is
definitely no stranger to taking
discarded ideas and carrying them over
to the next installment but that kind of
speaks for itself and on its own it's
not exactly convincing evidence as there
are many many ideas which didn't make it
into breath the wild and i highly doubt
we'll see all of them implemented in the
sequel so what else is there well let's
start with trivia story and lore
connections
although taking place in the same
overworld as its predecessor breath of
the wild 2 has been revealed to take
place at least partially in the skies
above hyrule as of yet we still don't
know what exactly this place is but many
are speculating that this isn't just
high above hyrule but perhaps a
different realm altogether reason being
is that in breath of the wild as well as
the footage from the sequel trailer
where link is on the surface the sky
islands are nowhere to be seen but how
does this relate to diminish well the
minis realm is said to reside in the
heavens or at least close to it this is
depicted as such in hyrule historia but
it's also told to us in the backstory to
minish cap sometime between skyward
sword and minish cap when hyrule was
being plagued by evil diminish appeared
from the heavens gifting the hylians a
sword known as the picori blade and a
golden light which is implied to be the
triforce i guess or at least part of it
but we'll cover that in a different
video over the course of minish cap's
adventure this legendary blade is first
broken then reforged by diminish and
subsequently infused with four elements
by link himself and henceforth became
known as the four sword thereafter
canonically this is the same blade
featured in four swords and four swords
adventures the existence of the four
sword is not irrelevant when it comes to
the possible story of breftwat 2 believe
it or not and this has everything to do
with the return of everyone's favorite
pigman ganondorf as of today it's still
not confirmed which timeline breath of
the wild follows up on but ganondorf
being back in his human form rather than
his alter-ego ganon has led to many
people leaning more and more towards the
child timeline i'm not going to get too
deep into why as that is a video on its
own and i'm not even making the claim
that the child timeline is without a
doubt where breath of the wild belongs
but it has mostly to do with the fact
that the corpse we see in the breathtak
2 teaser has similar characteristics of
that of ganondorf from twilight princess
as well as the fact that this is the
only timeline where we visually saw the
demon king transforming into malice
something that is referred to in
creating a champion here's the problem
though according to the official zelda
timeline twilight princess isn't the
last game in the child branch to feature
ganondorf but instead four swords
adventures here ganondorf has been
reincarnated into his human gerudo form
transforms into ganon and is last seen
being sealed inside the four sword so if
nintendo wants to keep at least some
story consistency and breath of the wild
in its sequel take place in the child
timeline technically ganon should be
inside the four sword unless he broke
free from it somewhere between four
swords adventures and breath of the wild
which is possible but then what happened
to the four sword and where is it now of
course it could be that nintendo decides
to totally ignore this part of zelda's
history heck many people even doubt if
four swords adventure's timeline
placement is accurate and should perhaps
be placed somewhere else but unless
nintendo ever updates the timeline it
remains where it is now at the end of
the child branch next is visual hints
from the recent e3 trailer for the
sequel first off we have a shield which
link is seen carrying that has a symbol
on it that is eerily similar to that of
vati the main antagonist from minish cap
if this symbol turns out to be more than
just a little reference this could be
huge in terms of a possible return of
diminish not only was vati the main
antagonist in the game which first
introduced diminish but he is one
himself or at least he was before
transforming into a demon vati is also
the only main zelda antagonist to have
directly interacted with ganon sure
ganon has interacted with other villains
before like xand twin rover general onox
and varan but these all turned out to be
side villains in their own respective
games and in service of ganon vati is
the only one who played the role of main
antagonist devoid of ganon's presence
only to meet him in a later game he's a
lot more ancient than ganon preceding
him by many millennia and is actually
the first prominent demon to make an
appearance in hyrule after demise's
curse is uttered in skyward sword vati
also has a close connection to the four
sword as he's been sealed inside it no
less than two times obviously i'm not
saying that vati will be present in
breath dwelt too but the fact that we
find a possible reference to him does
make a return of diminish more probable
after all who made this shield and how
does anybody even remember vati after
all this time another possible
connection to diminish are the green
robot creatures seen in the second
teaser it's not like we haven't seen
robots before in breath the wild but
it's obvious that the ones seen here are
very different from the shika made
guardians the minish cap details that
diminish have created automata in the
past the game features these robotic
soldiers and one of the minish in this
area explains that they themselves built
these machines to help the humans in
their fight against evil these
mechanical soldiers are also almost
exclusively found inside the wind ruins
which have a connection to a tribe that
used to live here and have since built
their new home in the sky and now here
we find robots who reside in the sky
there's also something else i want to
mention and i do realize that this is
definitely a stretch but remember those
weird reversed vocals we hear in the two
teasers well in the japanese german and
italian versions of minish cap diminish
actually speak in reverse and although
not canon this trait was even carried
over to the english version of diminish
cap manga again a huge stretch i know
but i still felt like it was at least
worth mentioning the next exhibit is not
in the form of story or visual elements
but in the form of a man hidemaru
fujibayashi director of breath of the
wild skyward sword and minish cap as
well as the guy behind the stories of
oracle of ages and seasons when he was
still working at capcom it's clear from
fujibashi's track record that he likes
to tell stories and in particular origin
stories the man himself has on camera no
less expressed regret that the idea of
minish-like creatures in breath of the
wild did not make it in it even shows
footage of diminished cap as
[Music]
like
[Music]
[Music]
since he'll be returning as director for
the upcoming sequel as well there is a
chance that he will go out of his way to
secure their inclusion this time around
and since the sequel will reuse the same
engine there will be a lot more time to
make it happen fujibarashi is the one
who came up with vati the four sword and
diminish so i'd imagine he would be
delighted to incorporate more of the
lore he created into the game especially
considering that breath of the wild was
already packed with references to
skyward sword most of which he created
as well at least story wise this leaves
us with one final question if diminish
would make a comeback in breathtak 2 how
exactly would that work in terms of
gameplay and what kind of connection
could they have to the main story in
minish cap link could shrink in size due
to eslo a cursed minish who possesses
powerful magic he is seen casting runes
around link after which he shrinks down
to minish size however the game never
states that this is the only way to
achieve this in fact it specifically
says that the hylians and minish used to
have a much closer connection and even
met with each other regularly not only
that but apparently even adults were
able to see them back then but over time
the two races grew apart for unknown
reasons it's clear that eslo's magic
power is not unique in this regard the
ancient highlands had magic of their own
which allowed them to speak to diminish
at the deepwood shrine which is said to
have served as sort of a meeting point
for the two races and perhaps in breath
of the wild too the magical abilities
link receives from his afflicted arm
could allow him to shrink as well and as
a final stray thought is it me or does
link's appearance in the breath wall 2
trailer look a bit similar to the
ancient hylian hero of men especially
the hairstyle but i don't know i'm
probably making connections that aren't
there anyway there is a lot more to talk
about when it comes to diminish but i'll
save that for a follow-up video where i
will talk more about the golden light
and some other ideas i have about this
era i think the idea of becoming small
could really work for breath the world
too it was already a joy to see hyrule
from a different perspective in minish
gap the way normal everyday objects
suddenly serve as tools obstacles or
even houses now imagine that but in full
3d it would also be yet another way to
make breath the wild's hyrule feel brand
new again despite the fact that we've
already explored this world even if the
minish don't show up i at least hope
that there will be some references to
them as there weren't that many in
breath the wild but the minish are a
crucial part of hyrule's history in my
opinion they forged a powerful sword one
of a few besides the master sword
capable of defeating ganon they bestowed
powerful magic upon the hylians in their
time of need and as far as races go they
might just be the one who reside closest
to the gods
[Music]
before ending the video i want to give a
shout out to bannon who gifted me an
amazing homemade minish figurine as well
as an awesome oil painting of breath to
waltz hyrule i cannot express enough how
thankful i am for this and well humbled
that you would want to give me such an
amazing piece of artwork which i'm
guessing took quite a while to make if
you're interested in one of these
figurines or other types of zelda art
yourself there's a link to their twitter
and facebook in the description if you
want to check it out not a sponsorship
by the way just a way to help a fellow
artist who's been so generous with me so
again a big thanks to bannon rest
assured that this little guy will be
sitting comfortably on my shelf for many
many years to come additionally a big
thanks to all of you for watching to my
mods my patreons and members who
continue to make my content possible and
to clifford longhead jr alexander and
mika for joining the crew it is as
always much appreciated and that is all
for now this is don signing off and have
a good one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you